hey everyone welcome to the waterlab
podcast for this prank i call damian
mckenzie as a member from the whoop food
company
just to see if i can get him to pose
naked for the up and coming calendar
a massive shout out for this prank has
to go to michael allardyce
and brad webber for setting the whole
prank up all i had to do was call him so
absolute couple of lads there and uh
anyway if you enjoy the prank
please share it if you don't all good
enjoy
hey damien hey damian it's willie here
from woop how are you
okay let's go with that boys
damien hey damian it's willie here from
woop how are you
good how are you yeah awesome uh
is now a good time to talk
yeah nathan's god oh my god awesome so
well
my name's willy and i'm the marketing
director for woop
hey guys nice to meet you yeah you too
and uh
okay i came across your name in the
client base
and i see that you're using our product
now
yeah yeah i just started using that this
is my first week actually
how are you finding it so just just oh
that's
awesome it's very um easy well you know
like especially after training just come
home it's probably
15-20 minutes it's perfect oh that's
i've been here three nights but it may
have been good
um branched out what i've eaten compared
to what i usually eat and
um food's good mate and it's just like
the best thing about so quick
yeah you buddy and then you don't have
to keep anything until
now i've been loved this week so far
that's great great great to hear and
i've i've spoken to greg
because we've got a bit of a problem he
mentioned that yesterday yeah we got a
bit of a proposal for
you and he he was pretty impressed with
it um
but he obviously wanted you to uh be all
over it as well
so we're looking looking to start a um
calendar yep and i know that
i've i've been a big fan of your jockey
shoots that you've done
previously yep you
you obviously got pretty good looks and
a really good body that we're looking to
sort of tap
into because you've got that profile as
well
okay yeah so um the plan of the
uh we've already got aaron smith on
board he's already signed up
so you obviously know him quite well
yeah
so what we're looking to do is sort of a
nude calendar shoot but using
fruit or vegetables to cover our cover
your bits
yeah how does that sound
i'm sorry i'm never really talking to
you to be here
i thought you'd be all over it with your
sort of jockey background
different different if i've got my graph
on but yeah okay well
that's right anyway yeah so obviously
um i've seen your jockey shoots and
we'll obviously probably need some
pretty big fruit for you i'd imagine
wouldn't we
[ __ ] there is anything made of work
yeah so we're looking to try and get you
on sort of the september or december
page yep
so are you are you pretty interested in
this
oh yeah like like you'd have to probably
just go through greg mate and just put
the finer details of it all and
yeah and um and go through him and then
use that
you know what happens and he liaises
with me and yeah
on what's required so um but yeah
oh yeah i got out there
what piece of like just so we could
start planning what piece of fruit would
you
prefer because we've got range obviously
from big size to watermelon
all the way down to blueberries
oh yeah okay um i don't know
jimmy magic
though
[Laughter]
yes so i thought maggie surely he wasn't
good
[Laughter]
because i mean oh what's the real cane
to get you on board
this episode was brought to you by
fortune favors beer
available at all good beer stores new
zealand white